-Our next guest is
a very funny comedian
who is currently on her "Ya Girl
Done Made It" stand-up tour.
For tickets and info,
go to mspatcomedy.com.
She also created and presides
in the courtroom show
"Ms. Pat Settles It,"
which airs Wednesdays
at 10:00 p.m. on BET.
Let's take a look.
-She pulls out the wig,
and I'm like, "Okay."
-Was it human hair?
-It was synthetic.
-Did you know that you
brought her a synthetic wig?
-When I got the wig,
it was fabulous.
-Is the wig here today?
-Yes, it is.
-Bailiff, can I get the wig?
-Your Honor.
-[ Laughing ]
-Oh, hell no.
-That's not the wig.
That's not.
-Your Honor.
-Why would you do that?
-That is not my work.
-[ Laughing ]
I can't look at it.
-Oh, hell on.
-Give it a spin so everybody
can see the whole hairdo.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Ms. Pat, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome back, Pat.
-Oh, thank you for having me.
Now, this is not a bad wig.
-What?
This is a good wig.
Yeah. No, you would -- if you
were trying to sue somebody
saying that was a bad wig,
you would lose your case.
-I probably would.
-You have a podcast
called "The Patdown."
-I do.
-I had a podcast.
And I hope you heard me
singing your praises
as a wonderful talk-show guest.
-So I have a fan base
called the Crack Baby
'cause I'm an ex-drug dealer.
[ Laughter ]
And they started sending me
this podcast
with four white dudes talking,
and I'm like, "Uh, I don't know
these white dudes."
So I sent it
to my white manager.
Shout-out to Reg Tigerman.
And I said, "Who is these
white men discussing me?"
And he was like, "Pat,
that is Seth Meyers."
I was like, "Holy crap."
-Well, I'm glad.
-When you with everybody,
you just sound
like another white guy.
-Thank you.
That's -- You know,
we do -- we do aim for that.
-Well, you did a good job.
-Thank you.
You are also --
You've been very busy.
You also -- tell me about
the Fully Loaded At Sea.
-Bert Kreischer did a --
-Very funny comedian.
He did a Fully Loaded tour --
I mean cruise.
So he said, "Pat,
come and perform on the cruise."
I said, "Okay, Bert,
I know your fan is all white,
so I got to gather
some black people,'
'cause I'm not getting on a ship
with 2,000 white people.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just going to keep it real.
-It does look like 2,000 people.
-It was 3,000 white people
and 22 Blacks.
-Okay.
And how many of the 22 Blacks
did you know?
-I brought all of them.
-You brought them all, yeah.
-I wasn't going down by myself.
[ Laughter ]
-You got to do some comedy.
You also got to judge
a belly-flop competition
and a Speedo competition.
-So the Speedo competition,
everybody was my size.
So I said, "Oh, I was wondering
why Lane Bryant
was out of fat-women underwear."
'Cause all the fat men
had them on as Speedos.
-Okay, gotcha.
That's very unfair.
-Yeah. Very unfair.
So I had to wear my husband's
boxers on the cruise.
-Your son came, as well.
Did he behave?
-No. So I have a son that likes
to get white-girl drunk.
-Okay,
-'Cause he --
White-girl drunk.
-Okay, gotcha.
-When you got to hold their hair
back and let them throw up.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Because he was raised
in Indiana around white kids,
so he gets lit.
-I see.
-So he crunked the cruise up,
because we was just on the sea.
We couldn't stop,
and I was like,
"I'm not about to roast
with these white people.
I got to crank them up."
So we get up
and we started dancing.
My son got so drunk.
I went back to my room.
They called me like,
"You got to come get Junebug."
We go to the pool.
Junebug, 22 years old,
motorboating an old
50-year-old white woman.
I'm like, "No, Junebug!
You gonna wake up
and regret this."
-Did the white woman
that was getting motorboated
seem to enjoy it?
-She was enjoying it.
But he didn't realize
those things went past his ears.
[ Laughter ]
-You did a newly-- You hosted
a newlywed game, as well.
Was your husband there?
-My husband,
I brought him with me.
And so I kind of
like coached him.
I said, "Hey,
you know about me, right?"
He was like, "Yeah,
I know everything."
So one of the questions was,
"Who is her celebrity crush?"
He said Denzel Washington.
I said, "What make you think
Denzel Washington's
my celebrity crush?"
My husband looked at me
and said,
"All old black women
like Denzel."
Ice Cube is my celebrity crush.
And who the hell
told my husband I was old?
[ Laughter ]
-Shame on him.
Now, I think this development
is the most exciting of all --
that you have
your own courtroom show.
-I do.
-So, "Ms. Pat Settles It."
-Yeah, and you know
I'm a convicted felon
and I've been on
the other side of the law.
So what make me a judge?
I mean, look,
Trump can be president.
I can be a judge.
-Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
So when you walk
into a courtroom as the judge,
you probably don't
feel nervous at all.
-Oh, no, I'm on the other side
of the law.
I don't have to look at a judge,
"I didn't do it, Your Honor.
I did it, but let me go."
-Now, what --
These are real disputes.
-Real disputes.
-What are some that have
stuck out to you?
-One stuck out to me.
It aired last week,
and it's this fat guy come in
and the lady's suing
for playing his own rap music
while he was supposed
to be their chauffeur.
And he had a rap song.
He said --
♪ I don't do no booth ♪
♪ Put me at a table, baby,
put me at a table, baby ♪
♪ 'Cause you be hurting
my navel ♪
-He doesn't want
to sit at a booth?
-Yes, 'cause he's fat.
Let me explain something.
When you my size,
we don't do booths
because it presses
on our navels,
so it cut off our circulation.
-So he wrote a rap song
about how he doesn't want
to sit in a booth
because of pressure
on his navel?
-Yeah, because that's why I sit
at a table, so I can breathe.
You can't eat a lot
if you're in a booth.
-Yeah.
It seems like probably no one's
ever written a rap song
about this before.
-No, but everybody enjoyed it.
All the fat people
are in my in-box.
They love it.
-So, did you let him off?
-No, I gave him the $400.
-Oh, you gave him the money?
-Yeah, he won.
-Now, this is real money, and
you get to decide who gets it.
Has anybody who works
at the show said,
"Hey, this is actual money"?
-So BET -- When I went
to BET to pitch the show,
they said, "Okay,
you can be a judge."
I was like, "Well,
I'm a convicted felon."
They said, "Well, it's TV.
You could be Jesus."
So --
[ Laughter ]
But nobody told me the cases
and money was real.
So literally, if I like you
and, I ain't going to lie,
if you was a little extra black,
I tipped you with a --
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Baby, you need
that money, a extra $2,000."
So all the producers come out
and they like, "Stop it."
I was like, "What's wrong?"
They was like,
"You're messing up the budget."
I'm like, "What budget?"
[ Laughter ]
They was like,
"The money is real."
I was like, "This real?"
I'm a convicted felon.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it couldn't have
worked out better for all of us
that you are now a official
judge giving away real money.
And it is just
so lovely to see you.
Thank you, Ms. Pat.
Please come back again soon.
Ms. Pat, everybody.
"Ms. Pat Settles It"
airs Wednesdays on BET.
For more info on her stand-up
tour, go to mspatcomedy.com.
Don't miss her. We'll be right
back with more "Late Night."